once the funny is out Adam Devine is in
no no no that's not true
no that's not true at all Adam Devine is
in ear of tonight as our special guest
goes but Nick Jonas is joining the voice
[Music]
make and his Joe Broz were mob leaving
dinner in West Hollywood last night all
the mayhem just four hours after the
singer broke the news I'm so excited
season 18 of The Voice you're gonna get
your butt kicked buddy
our mission destroy the feuding already
got started on Ellen and this happened I
think yeah that's a Blake look-alike
giving Nick a good scare this afternoon
Nick's wife Priyanka told us the other
coaches should be worried I know he's
super competitive and he likes to win
hope your season would entertain you
Nick he can be sparring with Blake yeah
I think I think that's gonna happen so
Nick's in but why is Gwyn leaving
et has learned gwen's Vegas residency
picks up on February 7th that's just a
couple weeks before the start of the
voices next season meanwhile we wonder
how will Nick be as a coach this feels
like a head well he's got a lot of
experience he's mentored on the voice
before four years ago then the x-factor
NBC song land and American Idol team
yeah Nick can be tough we saw it right
here on ET when the pop star critiqued
our own Cameron Mathison as he belted
out one of Nick's songs
Cameron Addison and Jonas jealous
[Music]
you literally have tell rhythm Wow
how was that I know what your teeth look
great
thanks man thank you see every single
one of them Nick had just one big
suggestion a lot of auto-tune
[Music]
[Applause]